Okay, so it is December 7th, 2017. Time flies when you're having fun, I guess.
And there's some things I want to go over because people have questions, and if you have
any questions, you can interrupt me anytime and ask the question whatever you have.
So don't be shy. Remember, we are recorded, and this is going to be posted on Facebook.
So if you are shy, and you don't want your name up in your voice, then you can certainly email
me for next week. Or if there's a bunch, sometimes I make an extra video like I did last
week, since I was gone. So make sure you watch that. I always post that on Facebook as well.
All right. So we're going to talk about thermography today because I like thermography, and it gives
us some valuable information. And I think the more you know, the better you can use that
information and help you. So a couple of things about the unit that we have. We use the
Medi-Urb. So if you go anywhere else because we see obviously patients from all over the
world in the United States, I don't know where they are, elsewhere outside of the United
States, but in the United States, there's multiple different thermography units. I'd suggest
you only go somewhere that uses the Medi-Urb. That's just by suggestion. Yes, I'm a little
biased, but it is the one that's FDA approved. And they do have a system that at least all the
data stored in the cloud in their banks. So if you come here and do thermography, one time
and then you go somewhere else and do thermography with the Medi-Urb practitioner, the radiologists
who review it could compare studies between the two clinics even though they're different parts
of the country. So there's some benefits that way. We also have access to thermography that's
done elsewhere. So that's a benefit. And plus, you get more objective with comparing studies.
It makes it more accurate. We're going to talk about accuracy of thermography and when you're
comparing a three-month study and six-month study, there is discrepancy of that no matter what
you do. And we're trying to, our clinic is actually trying to make things better for the whole
Medi-Therm community because we have some ideas that we're going to be implementing to the clinic to
make a more of an objective test on subsequent tests. So Medi-Therm are all over every, you can find
them if you just search Medi-Therm.com and locate a clinic near you. Most large cities have
somebody that's doing Medi-Therm in it or close by or that will travel. All right, so let's get started.
So why do you do thermography? Does it diagnose? How does it help us? What's the purpose in it? Well,
remember, thermography is taking a picture of heat. So that's what it's looking at is heat. So it
isn't diagnosing cancer. It isn't diagnosing disease. All that's telling us is where are their hot
spots and or cold spots. So it's looking at the heat differentiation and I'm not going to get into the
technicalities of the point, you know, what zero point temperature differentiation and colors.
But in bottom line, it's telling us where is their hot spots? Where is their cool spots? Because both
hot spots and cool spots could tell us something, could give us hints to something. Again, it's not
diagnosing. Let's give it a hints to something. So in a picture like this, you see this is a person's
breast. They're left breast. They got a lot of hot spots along this breast. Does that mean that they
have cancer there? No, it doesn't. It means they have a lot of hot spots along that breast. And then
you have to take clinical correlation based on that. What would produce heat in a person's body?
Well, an infection could produce heat. An infection would produce heat if it's an active infection.
Irritation of some kind would produce heat. So a person would have a picture like this if they
took their figure and they poke themselves there multiple times.
And then they took the picture because you just irritated the tissue there. That's why
we have those rules before you do the thermography that you're not, you know, putting lotion on your
body, you're not scratching yourself, you're not doing a heavy deep massage the night before,
something like that. So we don't want that would be considered what's called an artifact. We don't
artifacts, meaning incorrect abnormalities or false positives. This would be if somebody had
this read this here because they just scratched their skin really, really, really harder than they took
a picture. Well, that would should give us a false positive. Probably look much different than this
because it would look right where you scratched. And it wouldn't follow a line like this unless you
did a weird scratching position or something like that. But we want to be as accurate as possible.
So you try to take those precautions as far as preparation goes. And that's where there can be
inaccuracies because their biography is so sensitive, it's going to pick up heat. For instance,
this heat in the armpits here, what is that from? Is that mean this person has a malignancy in
their armpit? Well, of course not. So you take clinical correlation. This person walked in the
office with their arms down and they're going to have more heat in their armpit. No, this person has
heat underneath their breasts is not abnormal. No, they probably walked in wearing a bra so they had
irritation from the underwire of the bra and their breasts, okay, say down a little bit like this and
we're putting pressure so you had skin on skin pressure there, you're going to have more heat.
So this would be a normal fine deed of red. Right in here, this would be a normal fine deed of heat
in the armpits. Even in the in the lymph nodes here, this is the lymph that drains the neck,
obviously we cut off the picture of the person's head here. But is this normal? Is this abnormal?
Depends on what's going on with the person. So let's say this person, oh I just had a really bad
cold last week, then this would be considered normal. So it doesn't mean it's a disease process.
So then when you look at the body, when you look at the body with thermography, you split the body
straight down the middle and you compare left to right, everything you do that with except the rest.
So the breasts are considered separate organs in themselves and this could actually be a normal picture
of this person's breast. So that's why you do a three month follow-up. So let's say this person has no
history of breast cancer, they're just coming in for to do their first thermography and this is what
the thermography looks like. What this would probably be rated at some risk here because there is heat
there. We don't know what it's going on there. Should the person go and get mammography?
Well in my opinion, no. Should the person go get an ultrasound? Maybe. Should this person be doing
regular breast exams, palpatory? Yes. But then you'd want to get a three month follow-up. If it looks
the same at three months, this might be the person's normal. I would suggest getting another follow-up
maybe in six months looks the same. It continues to look the same over a period of time. This maybe
this person's normal. So you're comparing studies over time. Well if this is the person's first picture
then this is this is all we got to go by and then you have to correlate it back to other clinical data.
So you're just using a thermography like you'd use any other test to help you with differential diagnosis
with the patient that goes along with other clinical data and examination and other clinical testing
that may give us some information on what's going on with the patient. All we know is that there's heat
there. You also look at spots that are cooler like this could be a cyst right under here, a
breast cyst because they got a very circular cool spot around the red. So you see these
odd little shapes like this that's very possible that that's a cyst. But again you're not making a
diagnosis off of the thermography you're getting some hints. Always with the thermography the red is hot,
the white is the hottest and it goes down to blue. So this is a cooler spot here amongst this heat here
at a circular cooler spot you'd think there's a possibility of a cyst there. But it gives us hints.
All tests do is give us clues. Even blood work. Remember, oh I had an abnormal vitamin D level.
Well really what's abnormal? Well by this is the normal range. Well yeah that's the normal range
that is that's a range for a reason. People say well by I have a I'm running a fever. What's your
temperature? 99. Well do you ever take in your temperature before? Yeah it always runs a little high.
Well that could be your normal 98.6 is just average. So people can be you know you're unique.
And we don't want to compare you to a given norm that this is what your what your value should be.
cholesterol is a perfect example of that. When I went to school normal cholesterol was 220 or below.
Well then when they came out with statin drugs they decided and I'm not kidding here. They decided
that they could have 80 million more people on statin drugs if they lowered the normal. So they lowered
the normal to 180 so that then they could prescribe statin drugs for everybody that's over 180.
Now to me that's absolutely criminal. That's just absolutely criminal. Besides the fact that
statin drugs completely depletes your your coq tab and increase lip fatty liver and and a whole
bunch of other side effects of statin drugs. But it is the fact that having cholesterol of 220
in my book would be considered normal because cholesterol is needed to convert the vitamin D
in the skin when it's hit with sunlight. So a big part of the reason why people are so deficient
in vitamin D is they're trying to keep their cholesterol levels artificially low using statin drugs
pushing their cholesterol down. They don't have vitamin they don't have 25 hydroxy cholesterol in
the skin that's converts the vitamin D with sunlight. And we have a spike of cancer. It's certainly
a contributor to our increase in cancer rates. So it's just what is supposed to be normal. Yeah if you
have cholesterol over 300 that's a hint that something's going on with your liver we need to correct that
but you don't correct the class you don't correct the problem with the liver by artificially
manipulated the cholesterol done with the lipitor. So be careful of what normals are
and we have to compare you with you over time. And if you do have some things that look funny and
abnormal that we compare that with other clinical data to get to the root of it to help correct the
problem. Just like with cholesterol we still wouldn't use lipid or to lower the cholesterol level if
you're at 325 we'd find out why you're at 325 it helps flush the liver. Here's some other pictures
of that show different things. So this says healthy symmetry of breast this is it might type
it out here I stole this all off the internet but really you're not looking so much for symmetry
of breasts like oh there's look at how the coloration is almost identical between these two breasts
that's really not what you're looking for. People can have very abnormal coloration between two
sides of their of their breasts because remember the breasts are separate organs. If you have some
major discrepancy like this picture you think something's probably going on we got some hints that
something's going on. Here's a major discrepancy between this person's breasts something's going on
here. We need to look deeper. This is the person's first time obviously this isn't the person's
full first time you can see the breasts as much larger here than this one they already know something
is going on. But then you could use this picture over the course of treatment and see how that
changes it's just another another clue to improve it or go in the wrong way. That's why you do
subsequent testing. Typically just technically they always a thermography has got some kind of rules.
One of the rules is you really want to get a three four month baseline. Media if after your
initial thermography you want to get another one they say three months depends on where you're at if
you could get to a thermography clinic. And then at six months then at nine months and you're looking
at progression of a disease here and you can see some changes here some heat in this person's right
breast here. This could be completely normal. We see it a little bit more here. That starts to get
suspicious. We see it a little more here. Now personally I wouldn't just do this and this
and not do some other inspection whether it be ecclesiology exam or at ultrasound or palpitory exam
or whatever you're going to do. You might want to look into it what it's at this level not what it's
at. Wow I guess this is really progressing way down here at nine months. But this is how a disease
would progress over time. So it gives us a picture over time of what's going on and then it hits
and what we need to look for to help make some intervention. Also there's other things you look at. So
here's a picture of a person's feet obviously. There's really hot spots. Remember whites the
hottest here. Would this be considered normal? Maybe again you have to assess it with other
clinical data. Maybe this person you know how far did they walk coming to the office? How did you
have them sit and have their feet up for a half hour before you took this picture? All these things
are important to assess what you're really making a decision of is this normal or is this normal for
the person? If the person has a lot of pain in their feet and that's what you're
assessing that you would look for are there hot spots in the feet that could be causing some problems
and causing that person's pain? Did somebody have a question? Last week we talked about a video that I
made about dental infections. Heat around the mouth is never normal. So I said that heat in the
cytosis that will be listed on your report is abnormal. Many times that can be normal. People have
allergies, people have other issues and they could have some heat in the cytosis. Especially women
that pull their hair back and they did their hair and such you're going to have heat around the
hair line. Heat around the mouth is never going to be normal. So there's something going on there
and I like I said in the video last week that many times this is where thermography really shines
to find these little hidden infections that cause a lot of problems as I stated, hidden some
clinical meeting you have no symptoms of any tooth pain. Some clinical dental infections can
cause heart disease, can cause cancer, can cause all sorts of problems. So finding it on a thermography
scan before you have any symptoms can be really nice to start treating it. Other muscular issues you
can see on a thermography. A cold area over the heart can give you hints of cardiovascular disease.
So there's lots of benefits. What's really common with that we see is really cold areas on the feet
where the toes are completely gone. So I did thermography on myself and I should have pulled that
picture. It was a front to back picture. My left my left what you could not even see I dialed it in
we were playing with and I dialed it in so you could see all of my right foot you could not see the
toes and the whole half of my left what was gone I thought what the heck. So I do and I didn't have any
symptoms. I have no zero symptoms of pain in my left foot but I do have a history of years ago I
broke my fibula and sprayed by left ankle really bad multiple times in sports. So I thought what the heck
I don't have any symptoms of foot pain. Well it was about eight months later I started getting
paid and neuropathy in my in two of my toes on my left foot though I corrected it with the PEMF
but I should have done the PEMF right away but I don't know I just forgot about it I got too busy
but you can see neuropathy issues before the person even has problems and I'll tell you right now I have
many friends of mine that are doctors that are functional neurologists because I have a degree of
that also so I belong to several groups of functional neurology doctors that all they do is treat
neuropathy. There are so many people with neuropathy. neuropathy actually actually the leading cause
of death of people over I think it's 70 something is falling because they can't feel their feet anymore
so they don't know where their feet are in space and they're tripping and they're falling.
So neuropathy is a really bad problem neuropathy is a bad problem with chemically induced neuropathy with
chemotherapy patients but it's and it's certainly a problem with with diabetic patients with
neuropathy because the high blood sugars burn out the large diameter afferate nerves but it's a problem
throughout society so looking at a thermographic image you can see like this person definitely has
neuropathy going out of their feet already they also have a possibility of a clot here
so that redness that red streak this is a de-real great picture here because they blew it up that
that white spot right there could be a blood clot in their leg so seed vascular issues with
thermography is very identifiable so it becomes very beneficial for people with that abdominal issues here's
a great picture right here so I would ignore the heat the increased heat right along here because this
is probably where the patient's pants line was that's why it's real hot right in here but this heat
all over here up in here this is underneath this person's breast so I would ignore this heat right here
I would say this person probably has some constipation issues maybe some colitis issues
maybe some liver issues right here this is you could say possibly the spleen but I would correlate
it back to any symptoms the person has because this could be the the flexure for the from the
transverse to the decedene colon here that we're picking up this person definitely has got either
liver gallbladder or pancreatic issues right here for sure this could be bleeding from that because
this is so hot this could be all liver gallbladder or pancreas so yes could they have could it be a
stomach issue possibly to add no possibly so you got to relate it back and correlate it to other
clinical findings so thermography in itself is not going to be
determinate of any disease by itself so we relate it back to other clinical findings
any other questions on thermography because I got another subject I want to go over
Dr. Conor is a Dave Lopez on Massachusetts if what should one look for in looking for a local
clinic that does thermography what what should we be looking for once that time okay so look for a
clinic that does Betty Thurme so you might have jumped in a little bit later but it's the Betty Thurme
clinic that we want that you want to look for and you could call our office and ask our office too
they could go on the web Betty Thurme website but you can look up the Betty Thurme website in a
clinic near you where you're located you'll for sure find somebody that has a Betty Thurme
okay you did there for sure well thanks I did don't just a little bit later but yeah I missed
the very first part but thank you for that yeah and then then you probably want to do another
whole body to top the bottom yeah we did a whole body at you I believe and dumb you'd want to
do you want to do that right actually we did it just from the wait up for me okay so we did an
upper body on you so do the same thing that we did okay all right thank you any other thermography
questions okay another question that we get is alkalizing is alkalizing I want to alkalize my body
because I mean it's all over the internet right I got cancer and I want to alkalize my body
so we want to cover some of the myths and the realities of alkalizing because this is
this is um there's some misunderstandings about this um so how does uh how do you alkalize your body
do you want to alkalize your body what's the purpose of that and what's the purpose with cancer
and I've said multiple times if you read any of my information that you alkalize
there's information out there is that cancer can't grow in an alkaline environment to the reason
why you have cancer is because you're acidic well I would argue strongly against that topic
the cancer itself because it's rapidly replicated is going to produce a lot of lactic acid that's
going to spill over outside of the cancer uh in the maloo that surrounds this growing bass
and that is acidic so cancer itself by rapidly replicated is producing an acidic slime layer
around itself and unfortunately that ends up becoming protective for the cancer
because the t cells your immune cells sometimes are it makes it more difficult for them to penetrate it
so yes you cancer itself is acidic did it grow because it was acidic no it grew it created more acid
now in multiple other videos I talk about glycolysis that's the process of you utilizing glucose
so all your cells take in glucose it goes through a process of glycolysis and then at the
end point of glycolysis is peruvate pyruvate that is converted into a chemical called acetyl
coenzyme which then goes into the mitochondria into the crem cycle it produces a lot of ATP energy
that's really how your cells produce energy with cancer cells they like to survive by
eliminating mitochondrial function and they survive off of lactic acid and what I talk about in
multiple way genetic videos is that especially if you have there's a gene that helps convert pyruvate
into acetyl coenzyme if I have a lot of defects in my pdh genes in my hif1a genes that I will even be
more prone to produce lactic acid from pyruvate instead of acetyl coenzyme that's the cancer that feeds
off of glycolysis and people that have those defects are going to be much more prone to feed off of
glycolysis and lactic acid will have a greater degree of acidity around their cancer the cancers
will tend to be a little bit more aggressive and these are the patients that we put on a more ketogenic
diet now understand all cancer is going to feed off of glucose to some degree so that's why we don't
want anybody eating a lot of sugar I mean sugars should just be out of the question for any cancer
patient but there's some because of the specific defects that they have their cancer is going to feed
directly off of lactic acid and those are the people that we tend to put on a more ketogenic diet
typically they're fitted to more of the brain cancers some of the breast cancer some of the other
cancers so it the cancer is producing it is at acidity so is it good to alkalize ourselves how do we
do that the answer is yes it's good to alkalize ourselves how do we do that and can we measure by
degree of alkalinity so you could read some books and a lot of websites that will tell you to get a
pH strip and to stick it in your mouth and measure your saliva or measure your urine to see if
you're acid or alkaline now the problem with that is you have to understand some basic physiology
if I have cancer in my colon or my breast or my brain the cancer in around the cancer is what is acidic
that's what's acidic it's not going to make my urine more acidic or is it going to make my saliva
more acidic your body has what is called a buffering system and it buffers the acid alkaline base
so that you don't become too acidic or too alkaline your blood will never exceed never very more than
about point one from a 7.4 pH or you will be dead so it is it is total physiological impossibility
for a cancer patient to measure or any person to measure their urine or saliva and say wow a
more acidic or a more alkaline systemically no your urine is more acidic or your urine is more alkaline
or your saliva is more acidic or more alkaline than yesterday but it really has nothing to do with the
cancer so unfortunately though we'd like an easy way to measure acidity and alkalinity around a
cancer you just have to understand physiology it's not measurable unless we cut you open and stick a
pH strip in you and even if we did that it would change the pH because we just introduced oxygen to
the component so you cannot measure it better fact you could get confused and it can be complicated
if you're trying to measure urine pH or salivary pH and think that equates to any sort or any way of
systemic pH it's just does not make any physiological sense so there is misinformation about that I don't
see any value in checking urine pH if I just take a bunch of minerals I will spill them into the urine
and by urine pH will go up and I will believe that my body is more alkaline but all it is is by just
made by urine more alkaline however there are certain things that we need to do to alkalize ourselves so
alkalizing our body is very helpful because that acidic slime layer around the cancer does a lot of
bad things it stimulates the release of what's called matrix metalloproteases which is an enzyme that
breaks down the extracellular matrix extra outside cellular so that which is outside the cell
between the cells is not just a fluid it's a matrix and when the metalloproteases that are released
by the cancer break down those break down the proteins in the extracellular matrix and allow the
cancer just to like take hold that's the benefit of taking of taking enzymes also so some of you people
I have on a high enzyme therapy because with kinesiology that test it out the enzymes will help
root that out and break that up also the acidic the lactic acid stimulates the release of
more cancer growth factors stimulates agiogenesis which means agiogenesis increases blood vessel growth
into the cancer and lactic acid has been found to directly inhibit your T cells
already talked about that so how do we alkalize ourselves it has everything to do with our diet
not measurable we just have to eat the right diet so all these things on this list are actually
good for you but here's more highly alkaline things more green the thing is typically it's going
to be more alkalizing to you typically this list here is a better list these are more acidifying so
meats even though it's okay to eat some meat once in a while they are acidifying so remember it's not
whether that thing is acid in itself it's whether it's what it does to ourselves so this is another
misconception okay so I don't want to step any toes here of you that may be out there that already
have a water system that alkalizes your water so is drinking alkaline water beneficial for us
well fine drink alkaline water but not with your meals
so if you have a water alkalizer drink alkaline water but not with your meals you'd be better off
if you if you put some lemon in your water or you ate a good diet with a lot of vegetation
that you would be thinking you're going to buy a water alkalizer that's going to make you really
healthy so understand our stomach is the only place in our body that we want to keep extremely
acid especially when we're eating our stomach acid is responsible for breaking down carbohydrates
that's the process of digestion so digestion is the process of breaking down a food carbohydrates are
broken down by the HCl secreted by my gastric cells proteins are broken down by the enzymes secreted
by my pancreas into the small intestine fats are broken down by bile secreted by my liver
stored in my gallbladder so if I don't have HCl hydrochloric acid in my stomach if I'm not keeping
my stomach acidic I won't break down my carbohydrates I'm going to put more stress on my intestines
that's going to cause more gut issues and that could be a problem
so it's so what do I want to do so I should I drink alkaline water should I drink sodium bicarbonate should I
well if you do that make sure you don't do that with any food because you need acid stomach
when you consume food you need to break down your carbs so you look on this list look at lemons and
limes if I stuck a pH strip in this lemon would it be acidic or would it be alkaline
the pH strip of this lemon will probably be about 2.3 or something like that extremely acidic
so it's not the the fact that this is acidic it's what that substance does once you digest it
and absorb it what it does in your body is it alkalizing to your body or is it acidifying to your body
I've never tried it but if you stuck a pH strip in honey I don't know if it would be acidic or
alkaline it might be even alkaline I bet you're under bucks that if you stuck a pH strip in
dairy it would be alkaline because there's a lot of calcium in it so it's not that that is alkaline
or acid it's what it does to your body it's acidifying to your body so it's not whether the
substance is alkaline or acid is it is the substance acidifying to your body because as your body breaks
it down what does it do with the tissues or is it alkalizing to your body because as the body
makes it down what does it do with your tissues a big reason why these things are very alkalizing is
because the amount of enzymes in them so can you you say coffee is acidifying how would that relate
to doing the animals so it doesn't mean you're not eat either consuming any of these things
but if I'm drinking six cups of coffee a day and that's my major source of beverage that's
that's not really great for my body you know I can offset it by a fee that I'm eating mainly a
vegetable diet and I'm not eating any meats so it's just about balance it doesn't mean that you won't
ever eat grains I have a lot of people eating grains because we need to keep your weight on
though it's they're acidified but we're also eating a lot of vegetables too so it's about that
balance coffee is acidified but again the coffee and a coffee inama you're not absorbing a whole
lot of that coffee so you're doing the coffee inama in order to stimulate the parasympathetic system
and that you're expelled most of the coffee so you're not actually absorbing it so it's much less
acidified to your system any other questions about alkaline acid because I know there's a lot of
misunderstandings about this out there on the internet Dr. Connoza's data once again I'm not sure
if this is related but what happens when someone doesn't massacrate their food properly some people
just eat really really fast I'm a slow eater so I massacrate pretty well but some people eat really
really fast and what happens digestion wise in relation to what you're talking about right so my
dog is a perfect example of that yeah we gave him a piece of salami the other day and she swallowed
whole I swear so exactly so if you don't so okay so the process of massacration you're chewing your
food this is this is another little tidbit is it a good idea to gum no it's not a good idea to
gum very often you do it once in a while fine but chewing gum you're telling your stomach that you
got food coming and you don't have any food coming so you're releasing hydrochloric acid and you're
got where you're not going to have anything to break down and you couldn't end up hurting your
gut so the process of chewing your food stimulates hydrochloric acid production of your stomach
and remember there's two processes in getting nutrition out of your food digestion and absorption
so the process of chewing your food you're breaking down the food physically obviously into smaller
components also your salivary gland is releasing talent which also helps break down mainly carbohydrates
so you're partially breaking down carbohydrates by chewing your food by the release of talent
from your salivary gland and then you're swallowing it so it's your saving you're you're you're
really helping taking stress off of because you're chewing all your food off of your your
stomach your HCl and your paigrius so chewing your food especially for carbohydrates and proteins
is very important so your mom used to say to your food 30 times before you swallow it there's a lot
of truth to that eat slower and chew your food good good question yeah I do choose my food I've
done that for a long long time but I am around others who chew really fast and swallow I mean
they finish that plate long before I can go halfway through my own plate but for those people I'm
just curious for those people who eat like that is there a weight issue does that cause more weight
in the body later on to digestion or that cause only indirectly because what it's gonna do is
gonna cause a lot more stress on the intestinal tract because you got food going you know the food
sits in your stomach you know it's supposed to be digestive this is the same problem with people
have too little HCl which is which is about almost everybody and then it's it's created into this
ball of tested only partially digested and it just puts more stress on the whole intestinal tract
um increases possibility of constipation you're not gonna absorb nearly as much nutrition
and the food that you will absorb will probably be the glucose so indirectly because it add to weight
yes because the person would probably still be hungry and eat more so they'll consume they'll consume
more calories and they'll be absorbing the the most the most simplest thing to absorb which will
be the glucose so they're gonna be at a higher rate for diabetes or at least syndrome x having higher
glucose levels and that's certainly gonna cause more problems you're interesting oh I have one
of a little question you mentioned about the gum chewing I do too gum and primarily just to keep my
I suppose my my palate to my my mouth lubricated uh is there an alternative I can um look for uh yeah
so alternative would be you know have water in front of you all the time yeah and I use a
calorie water with you when I'm working or you know driving certainly so um it doesn't seem to quite
satisfying after a few minutes I found out that my mouth is on the dry side again the other thing you
could do is bring a little a small little jar of coconut oil with you okay it take like a teaspoon of
coconut oil every hour or something like that and swash it around in your mouth and and um and
kind of suck on that a little bit it's gonna dissolve pretty immediately in your mouth and then just
kind of swash it around your mouth and swallow that that will help lubricate your mouth so that you
feel like you're not dry as dry and it's gonna be a good fat for you okay all right I have a question
about weak grass I does that fall into a very high level of alkalizing because I hear just like
it's so weak grass would be agreed so you could think of just about anything that's gonna be
greed it's gonna be alkalizing but is is it really as amazing as you know I'm hearing it's
exgenating it's the most alkalizing form uh no not really but I mean there you got to be careful
and question anything that you're hearing a little bit but it's good at weak grass is great um
the are you juicing it? Masticating okay yeah weak grass is good is it is it tremendously better than
any of the other grades no my belief is that you should get as many as big a variety as possible
you look at the studies like the Okinawa study where the people are living to 120 years old the biggest
thing that they found with them is first of all they're eating everything organic second of all
the amount of the variety of food that they're eating on a daily basis was bite-boggling
so and you know they wouldn't eat anymore it just let's say if they were gonna have rice they'd
have a mixture of about seven different types of rice so they're vegetable mix it would always be a
mixture of a whole bunch of different vegetables and that was the that was the biggest surprise on
that study so um that's why I like products like greens first or greens product because you just
can't even how can you how can you cook you know you're trying to work 40-hour a week and it's it's
hard to stay on top of this so it just gives you you know an advantage of getting some variety in
there but we crest do eat that every day would be great and then just another quick question is
there a good exhaustive list of the kind of of alkalizing versus that because I find a lot of
contradictions tonight go on the internet like for example oranges I see them on both lists
and pineapple yeah the problem is is that there's no perfect way to measure this
so for instance okay beta beta is very acidifying but if you're eating grass fed
um organic beef that you know where it came from and there's no GMOs in it it moves a little bit farther
over this way oh Samad here that's that's acidified but it's kind of you know a little bit on the
better side but if you're eating farm raised Samad it moves way over this side so um that's what
makes it difficult if you're drinking raw dairy which I don't I don't think anybody with cancer
should be on dairy if you could help it um because it has growth factors and it stimulates
emtor but the average person if they're drinking raw dairy from their own goats let's say it's
going to be on this side if they're buying milk in the store it's going to be way over here and remember
acidified foods and alkalizing foods aren't the only things that we're looking for in a food
so just because grains are acidified doesn't mean we should never eat grains because the
purpose in in overall health isn't just to alkalize myself um in or or to to keep from being acidic
either so you got to look you got to take a little bit step back from just this talk and we're not
we're not only looking at that so there's obviously things okay whether whether this stuff down here
alcohol and fruit juice and soda was alkalizing or acidified it's just not good for your period
so um that you got to kind of bring it all in balance
easiest way to think about it without gone nuts oh is your greed vegetables are going to be the best
thing for you eat as many of those as you can different ways to cook them and prepare them and juice
them or whatever you're going to get them in you um your lemons and limes are going to be alkalizing
but we don't want too much citrus either and you need good fats so the your avocados your coconut
your coconut oil coconut should really be on this list over here um are going to be alkalizing
it are going to be good for you in a lot of different ways somebody else had a question there too
is dr. Clara this is Carol david's wife when you were talking about the coconut oil um and
switching that in your mouth i thought it's if you had like some silver filling that wasn't such a
great idea did i misunderstand that in the past no so you're right so i did i didn't bring that
piece up i i don't know you're to remember david if you have silver fillings in your mouth
but um you can still consume so if you do have silver fillings in your mouth you do not want to do
oil pulling that's what you do that yeah oil pulling is putting a tablespoon of coconut oil in your
mouth and swash it around your mouth for 10 to 15 minutes and then spit it out of the sink to hopefully
pull the workery and other metals out of your gums and through the buckle mucosa of your cheeks
um but you can't do that if you have metal in your mouth so if you do have metal in your mouth
yeah maybe you shouldn't swish it around your whole mouth but just try to lubricate his mouth a
little bit um not try to pull metals so you would put a tablespoon of coconut oil in your mouth
it'd be hard press to keep it in your mouth for more than a minute or so anyhow but yeah thank you for
clarifying i get it any other questions we've got oh my gosh
about 53 minutes here all right so if anybody has any more questions i'll answer them otherwise
make sure you email them to me anything i have a question about the rife machine if um if you can't
finish a whole cycle through the night is it okay like does it do any harm to pause it and then
finish it like later like you know the extra hour or two does that interrupt the benefit?
no it doesn't it doesn't change the benefit at all um now i understand i made everybody's program a
little bit longer that i think that they would stay in bed so don't be so able to think that oh my
gosh i didn't finish my program i got to get them finished don't i don't want you to think that way
okay so if there's an hour left it's not that big of a deal if you're busy to the hour every day
uh or more than an hour every day then um i will make sure you contact me and i will shorten your
program i'll decrease the dwell throughout the whole program so that we cut that back down but i
i have different different frequencies recycling themselves through that night
and um that's the benefit of having seven nights of programming i typically program eight and a half
to nine and a half hours knowing that you're going to maybe only be in bed seven and a half hours
just the reason why i do that is because hey if you're going to go to bed a little early one night
a week or two nights a week you're just going to get more time okay yeah i i hit run into the
biggest problem the longest cycle is on saturday night and that's usually the night when i go to bed later
and oh see i thought that's what we got a bit earlier it gets caught up on your rest
already i get it i get it so we need to go back down to this alcohol piece down here for you right
it doesn't necessarily have to involve that it's that's right that's staying up a little later because you
went somewhere you know family time yeah you talked about in your book about vitamin C and uh my doctor
had asked about doing vitamin C i v so our vitamin C i v is good thing to do um yeah there's a lot
of uh data that shows that vitamin C i v's can be very beneficial for cancer patients
vitamin C is a is an antioxidant and there's benefits to antioxidant therapy
high dose vitamin C has been found to be oxidative and that says it's directly killing the cancer
so just like chemotherapy it oxidative it kills the it kills cancer and it kills cells
well why would i do that i want antioxidants yes but if we do high dose of an oxidative we will also
kill cells and it can be more specific to cells that are in rapid replication so high dose
vitamin C tends to act like chemotherapy in a sense um in that in say that it could have some ill
effects on your body too so there are some negatives and precautions with vitamin C therapy if you
don't have a port it could be very hard on your vessels um some people worse than others uh and so but
there's but there's benefits as well um it uh if you if you're considering doing that i should do some
just let me know like the girls don't call the office that you're considering doing it so
i could do some distance kinesiology whether that's going to be the right thing to do for you at least
in my opinion so that's unfair oh thank you what about just vitamin C supplements like wouldn't that be
helpful at least it can so if you're going to supplement with vitamin C go back and watch my
video on what are good vitamins bad vitamins so if we're going to supplement with vitamin C we want
us to supplement with a whole food vitamin C because remember in from that video that when vitamin C
was first discovered that the microscopy available at the time of the scientist's discovery only showed
the outer shell of the vitamin C and he called it a scorbic acid so vitamin C is hence now defined
as a scorbic acid which is easily made in a laboratory we made it in biochemistry or organic chemistry
class when i was in college so that is vitamin C however that's not what vitamin C is in nature a
couple years later when microscopy has improved they found out that oh my gosh this that was just the
outer shell vitamin C has all these other nutrients inside of it well too bad it was already labeled
so you're you want to get a vitamin C that's a whole food vitamin C uh there's not a lot of companies
that make whole food vitamin C where do you get whole food vitamin C number one is from your food
so you're eating all this vegetation you're getting a lot of vitamin C if you're by
organic vegetables so you get more vitamin C in an orange or a carrot probably in a carrot
so you get vitamin C in your vegetables you can buy whole food vitamin C supplementation standard
process is one company that specializes in whole food since the 1930s i think there's another one
was Garden of Life that i used to recommend but Garden of Life just got bought out by Nestle
so it's like okay i'm not using them anymore so i'm a little prejudice
got one more quick question what's the digit or the new test stand and what was the name of the new
genetic test you're doing so the new genetic test we can't release the name yet
and we're hoping to have it by next week hey so that would be great i have a real quick question can
you get vitamin D from the sun through a window um good question the answer is i know i don't believe so
i think you need the i think you need the um the beta waves and i think the window blocks the beta waves
about 80 percent yeah the blocks a lot of it and remember you can't get vitamin D you don't produce
vitamin D unless the sun is hitting your skin and you have to have enough 25 hydroxy cholesterol in your
skin in order to to bake vitamin D from UV waves hitting your skin so if i'm taking my walk out in the
winter and i'm all bundled up and only my face is sticking out i'm not getting so you're gonna have to
walk in your bikini whether it's whether it's cold or not all right well we better stop here because
we're at an hour now and nobody's gonna listen to this video but hopefully you guys got a lot on
of it um and make sure if you have questions email them to me because um otherwise i don't know to
address them so um about a half hour before each talk i go oh what should i talk about today so
i quickly threw this thing together so i'd rather talk about what you guys want me to talk about so
make sure you email be your interests thank you okay this will be up on facebook
thanks a lot and have a good night you bet bye bye